uh let's check in next with ben from
charleston south carolina ben you're on
the air
hey david
how's it going it's going well thanks
what's on your mind today
yeah a long time listener first time
first time catching the stream so thank
you um yeah so i have two things so one
you might even call it a critique of the
dave impactment show please and then the
second would be a uh would be a short
question afterwards okay so
i
noticed it might have been uh yesterday
or a couple days ago
the
topic was the
march for life rally okay
and
so i noticed
that in your speaking about the march
for life rally
so i really respect the david pakman
show and what you do here because it's
one of the few
political commentary shows where i know
that you have a respect for um
critical thinking right
and
i worry that sometimes with like a few
different topics
you sort of allow yourself to have this
the kind of
categorical straw manning you might say
that some others engage in so for
instance a sort of verbatim phrase that
i heard was used was you know these
pro-life people
uh don't respect women's choice
something along those lines and i just
want to caution because i do know people
personally
because i have a graduate degree in
philosophy
that have carefully considered the moral
justifications and moral ramifications
of the issue of abortion and have just
come to the conclusion looking at the
different moral considerations of that
complex topic and said
look uh you know a fetus has
the you know full status of a valuable
human human life and therefore you know
is
entitled to protection by the state over
and above uh bodily autonomy so
do
do there exist lots of people in the
pro-life crowd that really just want to
go back to the 1940s and 50s where uh
women have less rights absolutely
there's no question about it but we have
to be careful not to extend that to like
everyone that holds that particular
position
okay yeah i mean there's a lot there and
i'm so what's the what's the fallacy i
fell prey to because like sure there's
people that come to be anti-abortion for
different reasons i i would grant that
but what's the critique of what i said
so the critique would be um maybe like a
hole to part or a generalization
um
so saying like grouping everyone that
has a particular view into
uh other particular views that you see
is antecedent so um you know these
pro-life people don't respect women's
choice whereas there are actually
philosophers that have seriously
considered you know the the the
trade-offs between choice versus um
versus uh rights and what counts as a
valuable
life but it sounds like but if i can
unders if i understand what you're
saying you're saying sure there are
people who are against abortion
whose interpretation of when life begins
means that it is a higher priority
to prevent abortion than to allow women
to choose right is that i mean that's
basic they've they've come to a
particular conclusion where the woman's
ability or right to choose
is not as important as preserving the
fetus right i mean that it just sounds
like you're saying some people have some
people are against abortion because they
don't think that the woman has a right
to choose given the circumstances
right
so i acknowledge that i mean there's
lots of people who don't think that it's
a woman's right to choose yeah
well
so we have to be careful here obviously
so obviously we would say that um it's
not anyone's right to choose to
uh kill someone as an adult right i mean
this your it's not your right to choose
when to kill someone as an adult um so
abortion is a very complex topic in that
it
it deals with things like consciousness
personhood uh choice
i mean there's no
one way to define when a fetus is a
person i i think that you know right 100
people would have a hundred different
opinions on that
yeah it's complicated i just i just
caution against the sort of um
inflammatory language and like i said it
doesn't happen often because i really
respect the show
where you have a commitment to to
critical thinking um i just caution
sometimes with the categorical
uh speech where we're not lumping
everyone into a sort of camp especially
like just oh well you have this
conclusion well it must mean you have
these reasons which are pernicious
okay so it was so it's the reasons
you're saying there are people who hold
the belief i mentioned
but they hold it
after thinking about it more deeply
right yeah okay all right i'm totally
open to that yeah totally open to that
okay and then the little little question
uh afterwards is so i
like i said i have a graduate degree in
philosophy and um i'm currently a
science teacher at a high school um i'm
partitioning pretty hard to
my administration to be able to teach a
critical thinking class next year
i really do believe that critical
thinking class should be a core
class maybe even required in a high
school setting
do you think do you agree with me and
then what what in your view is the best
way to achieve that yes i i 100 agree
and because i don't know enough about
how
local school curricula are determined i
would not be the right person to advise
on how to make it a reality i would talk
to education activists about about that
i appreciate the call i've got a lot of
people holding so i'm going to move on
we're going to take a very quick break
and then we will be right back with more
calls so if you're holding on to talk to
me don't hang up quite yet
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video